On the outside, it may seem like
we haven't changed much
from our early ancestors.
But take a closer look and
you'll discover that humans
are still evolving in
some fascinating new ways.
The average person can hold
their breath for 30 seconds.
But Bajau people in Southeast Asia
can hold it up to 12 minutes
which comes in handy when they free dive
over 230 feet for food.
Part of the reason is simply
training and experience
since they spend over half
their workday underwater.
But it turns out, the Bajau
also have a genetic mutation
that makes their spleens
50% larger than average.
Our spleens are what filter
and store oxygen-rich red blood cells.
So, when the Bajau dive underwater,
their larger spleens contract,
which boosts oxygen levels
in the blood by up to 10%,
allowing them more time to collect food.
It's a handy adaptation that probably came
from living on houseboats
for the last 1,000 years.
About 35% of the world's
population has the equivalent
of a genetic superpower.
They can digest milk as adults.
Not impressed?
Then consider this.
Humans are among the only mammals
on the planet with this ability.
Thanks to a genetic mutation
that popped up in Europe
around 5,000 - 10,000 years ago.
Those with the mutation produce lactase
throughout their lives.
That's the enzyme that
breaks down milk sugars
for easy digestion.
And for most of history,
humans stopped producing
lactase after childhood.
But once those lucky few
Europeans could drink milk
as adults, that suddenly
meant extra nutrition
and ultimately healthier, longer lives
so that they could pass their superpower
on to future generations.
Today, roughly 95% of northern
Europeans have the mutation.
The human body has an estimated
20,000 - 30,000 genes.
And while some mutations can
change our spleens and diet,
others can protect us against
deadly conditions, like AIDS.
Nearly 50% of women in parts
of South Africa have HIV.
But researchers found that
some show stronger resistance
to the virus,
taking longer to develop AIDS
or sometimes never getting it at all.
Turns out, these women also
share a mutation in the gene
called HLA-B27 that the others lack.
Are we going to evolve
our way to HIV immunity?
It's too early to say.
But one thing's clear.
Evolution's not done with us yet.